as much we love Izzy here Izzy or Alex
wins this fight your next fight's gonna
be against harms that name which one of
those two gentlemen beat hamsa is the
winner of Saturday's fight your prize is
fighting homs at 85 and you're gonna
find out how good he is you can't do a
third fight even even if it's one and
one I don't know I just I don't see it
unless it's uh a judge's decision it's
like super controversial and it's not
really a clear winner the thought
process there is the first time they
fought is he won the majority of the
rounds got clipped they run it this time
let's say is he tkos them you wouldn't
be like well he won the first fight
until you got clip he dominate him this
time nobody's really asking for a third
time I just I don't see this happening
no matter what happens